is there a concrete example of something
where you you said you said something
and I'm not thinking of anything in
particular I'm being entirely genuine
here is is there an instance where you
feel you said something that appeared to
be true to you at the time and knowing
what you know yes I think I was a little
I think I was a little dismissive of the
men going their own way because I think
I called them pathetic weasels which and
I have my reasons for that my reasons
were roughly speaking that who are the
men going their own way well they're a
group of people mostly on the net who
have had who've been burned in their
relationships or who conceptualized
themselves as having been burned in
their relationships and they believe
that the legal structure in particular
in Western countries is so tilted
against men particularly in family
dispute situations that a divorce
settlement that it's safer for men not
to establish permanent relationships
with women not to cohabit with them ever
and they're a large movement now how
large they are I don't know but they're
large enough and they have what I would
regard as an undue influence over
relatively bitter and resentful young
men who haven't had great success in the
dating market and who are looking for a
rationale to write off all women because
they they're so hurt by their continual
rejection and that is not good for those
young men and so the reason that I
disparaged
the men going their own way was because
I had seen the pernicious effect these
are often older guys the pernicious
effect of their world-weary philosophy
on young men now these guys think that
they're just warning them and they are
warning them but they're not just
warning them now the reason I regret
calling them pathetic weasels is because
they also have a point I do believe that
the court systems are staggeringly
anti-male absurdly horribly anti-male
and I've seen my own clients some of
them who are really really decent
hard-working family-oriented people
demolished by the court systems and and
so the men going their own way have a
point
and so I'm sorry that I called them
pathetic weasels but i but I outlined my
reasons and so yes I do regret that I
have to be careful because I do have a
satirical dark satirical sense of humor
and I can utter epithets let's say for
the sake of punctuating a point
well simultaneously forgetting that
150,000 people will listen to it so so I
regret that